Is it foolish to try to get rid of breast cancer without doing the mastectomy since they can't do a lumpectomy due to the cancer me
Lobby learned it all for quadrants of the breast
Thank you. I'm trying
I'm willing to try via your program, but I do not want to be foolish. I wouldn't I that I
Totally agree with the way you worded this you don't want to be foolish
So when you but it doesn't mean you want you don't want to be foolish and just doing what they tell you either so you're trying to keep a balance there
Use wisdom so okay, I don't they're saying I should get a mastectomy
I think I'm gonna try some alternative therapies first to see if I can do it without a mastectomy and then I will be on my way through
Alternative therapy is that if this continues to grow and I decide to do a mastectomy then I'll be that much
In a much better position to heal
I think that's wisdom
I don't want to do a mastectomy, but I'm willing to do a mastectomy to save my life if that's what I have to do
But I'm not willing to just jump into that hoop immediately. I think that's let's use it wisdom. So if
In this case, let's say I start out an alternative protocol. I'm doing the right
If I'm doing different therapies and I'm doing different supplements and let's say the cancer is continuing to grow
Maybe it's slowed down a little bit. Maybe it hasn't but it's continuing to grow now
I'm gonna decide I better go and do a mastectomy. You're gonna be in a much better position or
Let's say a better case scenario. Say it has a grown at all. It's you know, it's just staying absolutely steady
I think I'll just stay on this pathway for a period of time and maybe not do a mastectomy. So
Those are the kind of things that you go through that decision-making process. So I think yes
I don't think you should be foolish or just dogmatically take a position either side